hey everyone I'm Abby from Abby's
kitchen welcome back to our series
enlightened by intuitive eating now in
our last video we discussed principle
number two of intuitive eating on your
hunger so if you haven't watched that
video go check it out by clicking right
here and then come back to watch this
one I want to start by of course giving
a big thank you to Alyssa Rumsey and Amy
Gloin who are intuitive eating coaches
and fellow registered dieticians for
reviewing this content I'm gonna leave
some information about Alyssa and Amy in
the description if you're looking for
some one-on-one support now before we
get started I want to answer a reader
question Dear Abby I want to eat
intuitively but I am fully vegan and I'm
worried that these concepts may be at
odds since I do restrict animal products
in my diet I also worry that if I don't
track that I may come up short on
important nutrients can I be an
intuitive eater without giving up my
moral values around veganism this is
such a great question and one that I've
been asked a lot about so the answer is
absolutely it's important to first take
a look at you know why you're choosing
to live a vegan lifestyle
are you eating vegan to lose weight are
you trying to prevent yourself from
eating bad foods these are reasons that
are obviously not in line with the
principles of intuitive eating even if
it's not currently why you're vegan
think back to determine if controlling
foods detoxing or restricting without
dieting was part of your initial reason
for going vegan I really want you to ask
these questions and do a deep dive to
get to the root of how and why you're
living a vegan lifestyle to ensure that
it's still there to support you and your
well-being most vegans who have a good
relationship with food abstain from
animal products for ethical
environmental and/or spiritual reasons
as part of a vegan lifestyle many vegans
do not even identify animal products as
food so just like your I wouldn't call
paper food or dirt food or poison food
they would view animal products as
inedible so in this case avoiding or
restricting animal products isn't the
same as restricting food for the
purposes of weight loss or clean eating
it's simply that the person doesn't see
animal products as being part of their
food
environment so limiting or restricting
them is not an act of denial it's
actually a really similar experience for
somebody who eats kosher or someone with
an anaphylactic allergy to peanuts
their food environment does not include
pork or peanuts in those examples so the
dietary choice is not coming from the
same sense of scarcity that one might
experience with dieting it's also
important to note that veganism is not
about restricting food groups you can
still have grains you can still have
vegetables and fruit and you can still
get your protein from amazing
plant-based sources like tofu tempeh
nuts seeds etc as for the question of
how do I ensure I'm getting all of the
necessary nutrients I need without
obsessing I think there's a big
difference between a meal plan and meal
planning I think a good dietician could
definitely help take a look at your
current eating habits and focus in on
how those habits affect your micro
nutrient intake with some recipe ideas
and some meal planning support not a
strict meal plan so this might involve
keeping tabs on what you're eating for
just a few days not forever and then
together looking at what you're eating
to see which staples contribute those
really important nutrients and what are
some options to maybe add in in the
event that things are coming up short
ideally we should not have to eat the
same thing every single day to ensure
that we're getting enough of those
nutrients but I also appreciate that we
may need a little bit of guidance here
there when you're in those early days of
transitioning to a fully plant-based
diet
so to summarize a vegan diet that is
aligned with intuitive eating would mean
not restricting any particular kind of
food group and allowing yourself
permission to eat all of the foods that
you identify as being food so I hope
that clears things up now in this video
we're going to be discussing principle
number three make peace with food this
is a really important part of the
intuitive eating series because it
really emphasizes the importance of
rebuilding your relationship with food
and as always these principles are
coming from the intuitive eating book by
dieticians Evelyn Triple E and Elise
rush so I will leave the link to that
below it is a must by now when it comes
to intentional
weight loss diets they all have one main
thing in common
restricting certain foods or amounts of
foods and this is exactly why I believe
the research suggests that diets are not
effective long term they force you to
ban certain foods from your diet and
assign good or bad labels to them funny
thing is when we restrict food we tend
to want it more than anything and when
we get it the reward center of our brain
starts firing off this principle
actually applies to pretty much anything
think about when you're sick and you're
stuck in bed for like a week after a few
days all you want to do is go outside
and breathe in some fresh air when we
can't have something we tend to want it
even more
we appreciate it even more kids are
notorious for this as well if you tell
them that they can't do something let's
just say I don't know go into your
bedroom you'll eventually find them in
your bedroom or like when I was a
teenager and my dad said that I could
not wear the skimpy crop top to school
it made me want to wear it even more why
because as humans we don't like
limitations we don't like being told no
and we certainly do not like feeling
deprived so in general deprivation can
actually increase our desire for
something the more you can't have
something the more you just want it
because it's now viewed as something
super novel and special so as soon as
you restrict food you place it in this
special box it becomes so special
compared to any other type of food sure
you can go without it for a while but
eventually just thinking about it all
day every day makes the restriction so
unbearable and you crack a good example
of this is chocolate a lot of people say
that they can't have chocolate around
them because they're just gonna eat it
all in one sitting
I mean we did a whole video all about
food addictions so definitely check that
out right here so what do these people
do well they don't have it at all and
they keep it out of their house
very typical I read about this all the
time but very quickly chocolate becomes
built up to be this magical forbidden
food with an enormous amount of power
over us once
finally come in contact with chocolate
again which let's be real it happens we
can't help but over indulge while it's
available because it's going to be
restricted again shortly after another
example is the days right before
starting a diet right before we go on a
diet full of deprivation many people
will go for a Last Supper and eat as
much as they can of all the bad foods
that they want but actually this tends
to backfire because we again just
telling ourselves that these foods will
be missed these foods are special so if
you have a ceremonious dinner before you
start a diet chances are that it's not
the best diet to be on does any of this
sound familiar honestly I see it every
single day and I too have experienced it
myself so I can absolutely appreciate it
but let's talk about some of these
restrictive diets because a lot of the
times just in casual banter and
discussion I hear from my friends and
family that oh it's going really well
but then there's almost always something
that comes up that causes a person to
cave or fail so here are a few of many
examples food competition this is a get
it while you can mentality now good food
marketers know that FOMO is a real thing
am I making food scarce you feel like
you need to load up on it and eat as
much as possible before it's gone this
could apply to like your favorite dish
or a bag of chips in the cupboard just
knowing that it won't be there for very
long creates an intense desire to eat as
much of it as you can number two
returning home I know I've got a lot of
great students who are watching my
videos and for anyone that goes away for
school you know the amazing feeling of
raiding your parents cupboards for food
when you come home if we go a long time
without the foods that were used to or
we love we start to miss it then once we
have access to it again we may sometimes
go a little bit overboard this of course
can happen with sweets and treats but it
can also happen with other foods as well
so for example a lot of people say that
they miss salad after being on an
all-inclusive vacation I mean remember
that video that I did about intuitive
eating on vacation like
all I wanted was salad and fresh raw
vegetables like crazy case in point we
don't like restricting ourselves on
either end of the spectrum number three
is the clear your plate mentality so
this mentality was especially true
during the Great Depression when food
was very scarce many families encourage
children to clean their plate as it was
totally wasteful to throw food out this
mentality has been passed on for many
generations now before I go any further
I want to just quickly flag that I am in
no way recommending that we throw out
and waste food I'm gonna be talking a
lot more about food waste and intuitive
eating in an upcoming video so stay
tuned for that I just want to highlight
the emotional and psychological toll
that this mentality can have on a
relationship with food so if you
commonly are depriving yourself you may
feel guilty about wasting a dish while
you're eating out and then of course you
end up overdoing it and eating past your
satiety signals instead if you were in
control of your eating and had a good
relationship with food you would know
that you could bring this food home for
leftovers and you can have it for lunch
the next day or perhaps you could just
share that dish with a friend there are
lots of different options that we can
explore okay so how is dieting possible
now if our biological and psychological
aversion to dieting is so strong then
how do people diet well if you've
watched my previous episodes you know I
have a strong admiration for our
brilliant body it's seriously so
intelligent people who diet all the time
aka chronic dieters are able to adapt to
long term dieting through an adaptation
process called restrained eating they
become so accustomed to ignoring their
internal hunger cues that they just
don't hear them anymore
these people tend to set up extremely
strict rules and completely ignore
anything their body and friends are
telling them they're able to stay on the
diet for quite some time until one of
their strict rules eventually is broken
or their willpower gives out essentially
they view their rules as all-or-nothing
I used to be this person when I was
struggling with orthorexia and even
still I'm not as comfortable living in
the gray so is there research to back
this up yes
there's quite a bit of research to
support the ineffectiveness of diets
that promote deprivation in one study
researchers split female college
students into three groups
no milkshake one milkshake or two
milkshakes after they ate the milkshake
they were asked to enter a private room
and sample different types of ice cream
they were all encouraged to have as much
of the ice cream as they wanted two
interesting things were found number one
those who are classified as dieters ate
significantly more ice cream than those
who are classified as non dieters and
second the dieters that had milkshakes
were much more likely to overeat ice
cream suggesting that a pre load of bad
food triggered them to forego their diet
and eat as much as possible knowing that
restriction would soon be following the
non dieters easily regulated they're
eating and stopped when they were
satisfied on the other hand the dieters
were unable to regulate their intake
which is a process called counter
regulation the researchers determined
that encouraging the dieters to overeat
cause them to forego their restrictive
inhibitions and as a result overeat this
overeating effect by dieters is known as
the what the hell effect essentially the
dieters believe that since they've
broken the rules of their diet they
might as well just go and overdo and eat
all the things in another study
researchers found that overeating was a
combination of restraint and impulsivity
if a person restricted food and it
exacerbated their drive for the food I a
ka increased impulsiveness then they
were more likely to overeat it a good
way to demonstrate this is a seesaw
example on the one end of the seesaw we
have deprivation and restriction and on
the other end of the seesaw
we have guilt when we're on a diet we
restrict and restrict which causes one
end of the seesaw to go up higher and
higher on the other hand we feel less
guilty because we're not eating any of
the bad foods so as deprivation goes up
guilt goes down but if you've ever been
on a seesaw you know that it reaches a
limit deprivation can only go so high
before it comes crashing back down once
it does we see guilt go flying up in
other words you feel like it because you
caved this is why I
hardly ever sustainable it creates this
up-and-down effect that causes chaos in
our mind and body however let's say you
balance out your deprivation and
restriction you don't restrict anything
but you're in tune with your body's true
needs this also balances out your
feelings of guilt because you no longer
are feeling bad about over indulging and
you're not flying high on the fact that
you're eating perfectly as a result
you're in balance so how do you make
peace with food now I know you're
thinking okay Abbi that's great and all
but how do I even start
the answer is to give yourself 100%
unconditional permission to eat no
restrictions no rules just pure
permission I also want a flag that well
this sounds super scary and also like
how the hell can this be healthy I'm
going to just eat chips and ice cream
all day long and a dietitian is saying
that is cool know that this is not all
intuitive eating is to believe that is
completely misconstruing the concept and
the research that supports them
intuitive eating has ten important
principles that build on one another and
we need to reject the diet mentality and
make peace with food so you can rekindle
your trust with your food and body
before we can implement gentle nutrition
guidelines this is really important and
we will get there but there are a few
important steps that we need to get
through first until you 100% believe
that you're allowed any food you will
always feel a sense of deprivation even
if there isn't physical deprivation
happening so what does this look like
well first of all we need to toss out
the idea that there are morally good
foods and bad foods I will not deny that
foods may not be nutritionally equal I'm
a dietician I mean I know way too much
about the fiber and fat content of foods
but if we make them morally equal we're
less likely to obsess over them and we
can better stay in control and second we
need to get rid of any strict conditions
surrounding food so for example thinking
oh I'll eat this today but I'll have to
work out another hour tomorrow as soon
as you start allowing yourself food
freedom you take away the power food has
on you and you
really decrease the chances of
overeating so are you going to overeat
at first yeah I mean probably as you are
essentially going off the diet which we
know from our experience tends to lead
us to overeat but once you become
accustomed to being around all types of
foods they actually start to lose their
specialness so what does the research
say about this working now at first this
will seem like a huge challenge but
remember it takes time to dispel all of
the dye culture BS that's been fed to us
for years and years as you start to take
the power away from food you will
naturally feel less inclined to eat it
all of the time in fact even if you
allowed yourself to eat a lot of cheetos
you're eventually gonna get tired of
them research calls this phenomenon
habituation basically the more a person
is exposed to a food the less appealing
that food becomes a good example is if
you're going on vacation you're going to
a resort and you see a huge table of
all-you-can-eat food all your favorite
foods so you're probably going to fill
your plate with a lot of these foods
I've done it you've probably done it
we've all been there but as the days go
on you might actually start to gravitate
towards having a salad or maybe some
fruit for breakfast you probably won't
create a whole mountain of food on your
plate near the end of your holiday and
it's often that the novelty and
excitement factor can cause us to
overeat but if we're used to it and
we're no longer assigning that moral
value to food those who just become
normal and totally less exciting this
was found in a 2011 study in which
participants were given mac and cheese
daily or weekly for five weeks YUM
so the researchers showed that
participants that had the mac and cheese
daily slowly started to eat smaller and
smaller portions on the other hand those
that were given the mac and cheese
weekly ate similar amounts throughout
the research project the author's
attributed this to a phenomenon known as
the sometimes opponent processes
theories - habituation basically when a
food is introduced a memory for this
food is created and activated to a high
level called the a1 state however the
men
eventually starts to decay over time and
enters an 8 - state if a food is
introduced shortly after when it's in
the a 2 state the stimuli for this food
won't be as strong
however if enough time has gone by that
the person has limited memory of the
food then they go right back to the
excited state of this food and therefore
have a higher drive to eat it what I'm
saying is by allowing yourself regular
access to all the foods they kind of
lose their novelty and you don't feel
such a drive to overeat them also keep
in mind that we constantly fall victim
to self-fulfilling prophecies simply
believing that you're going to fail
almost always leads to our perception of
us failing so believing that being
around chocolate will cause you to
overindulge may cause you to overindulge
you need to develop trust within
yourself that you can do this you are
capable of listening to your body this
intuitive eating journey is all about
rebuilding your relationship with both
food and yourself now one question I
know I'm gonna get is what if you only
want junk food now first of all part of
this exercise or step in the intuitive
eating protocol is to try to not think
of it as junk food the goal in the stage
of intuitive eating training is to treat
all food exactly the same so well I know
that it's in our culture's vocabulary
the best thing you can do is ditch that
kind of talk when we get to gentle
nutrition and honoring our health we
will do a deeper dive into which foods
better support our physical and mental
well-being second when you're given free
choice you may feel like you have an
all-access ticket to eat unhealthy food
and you do now you may enjoy some extra
fun foods for the first little bit but
over time you're likely gonna start to
crave variety and what legitimately
feels good to your body we will be
chatting more about this in an upcoming
episode so definitely stay tuned for
that
now Abby giving up structure is way too
overwhelming for me can we tackle this
in baby steps yes I know that this is
super scary for people so sometimes I do
recommend some baby steps to help
neutralize these trigger foods as we
sometimes call them breaking it down
into some baby bites
this feels a lot more manageable than
the lofty idea of just throwing caution
to the wind on everything so choose one
food to start with and let's attack this
with some structure in my book the
mindful go cookbook I disclose that my
trigger food used to be sugary cereal if
it was in the house I would eat it
mindlessly all day long so as a result I
just wouldn't buy it out of fear that I
would lose control so my intuitive
eating journey with it started with me
buying some cereal then I told myself I
could have cereal every single day if I
wanted and I did I did want cereal the
first day I found I had my breakfast
with cereal and I still wanted to kind
of snack on it later on in the day just
like out of the bag but soon enough I
actually didn't have that desire to
snack on it and I wasn't even that
excited in the morning anymore to have
my sugary cereal breakfast it very
quickly just became another food one I
enjoyed but not one that I was like
obsessed over and I started to implement
some gentle nutrition I noticed that I
was hungry soon after having my cereal
so I started to mix it with some brand
cereal or some Greek yogurt to really up
the satiety factor and then honestly the
next time we just ran out of sugary
cereal in the house I kind of just
forgot to buy it again it lost its power
it really was no longer so enticing once
you've had success neutralizing your big
trigger food you'll maybe have a little
bit more new pham confidence that this
can be applied to other foods that you
have either consciously or unconsciously
restricted or you're viewing through a
moral lens for this week's homework I
want you to start reintroducing foods
that you've previously restricted here's
how number one write down a list that
are appealing to you number two check
off any foods that you actually allow
yourself to eat regularly and circle any
foods that you've restricted in the past
or present number three
plan to allow yourself to eat one of
those forbidden foods as much as you
want either at home or in the store or
in a restaurant wherever you want number
four
while you eat the food check in with
yourself think is this as good as I
remember if it is then of course
continue to allow yourself to have it
now on if it's not which honestly is
common then it could be that your
history of deprivation has caused you to
put it on a pedestal in the first place
this is how I feel personally about
Halloween candy I used to crave it all
the time when I was restricting sugar
but it literally does not taste good to
me anymore and I can easily have it in
the house and ignore it you can start
with just one food if you're more
comfortable before tackling another one
on your list or you can go all in if
that feels easier to you everyone's
going to be different I want this to be
your journey and to take it at the pace
that you're comfortable with and if it
gets too scary then you just need to
take a step back that is okay too you
are not failing even proving to yourself
that you no longer are obsessed with
cheese or cupcakes or cookies is usually
really good data to prove that other
foods also don't deserve so much power
either now before I finish I just want
to highlight something really really
important a lot of criticism around
intuitive eating is that it promotes
overeating and overindulgence of food
the idea of intuitive eating is to make
peace with food and to welcome any kind
of food into your diet it's not about
overdoing it and eating whatever you
want whenever you want and however much
you want but here's the difference it's
actually about listening to your body's
needs you have permission to eat
whatever you want but doing so without
listening to how your body feels will
not be a satisfying experience sometimes
some emotional eating is normal and the
key here is to not punish yourself to
fall back into that binge restrict
repeat cycle but if you're eating beyond
your needs all the time or you're
relying too heavily on food as an
emotional coping mechanism
that's not supporting your health either
I mean it's not a fun experience when
you're sick to your stomach and
ultimately food does not solve all of
our problems this is a situation where I
would suggest speaking to a therapist
even if you're not physically
restricting food and just seemingly
overeating there may be some
psychological restriction going on and
trying to force your relationship with
food into a neutral zone without
addressing some of the
we'll likely keep you trapped in the
diet cycle
remember that intuitive eating takes
time to learn and it's really about
respecting your body's natural cues so
continue to work on these steps
throughout the intuitive eating journey
and stay tuned for our next video on
principle number four challenge the food
police so guys as always I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you have any questions about
intuitive eating or any other kind of
topics that you want me to cover in an
upcoming video subscribe to the channel
and I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
you